Harbor no she's one of the very new
camps established for the displaced
after the recent skirmishes in the south
of ed Lib in a time of destitution
everybody has to share there are 17
people crammed into this tent Marian was
displaced from Saraqeb a month ago
despite her own suffering she opened her
doors to her relatives who were also
displaced from Saraqeb just five days
ago and even OODA my husband left us a
year ago and me and my kids are living
here in the camp thank God I have eight
children and another one got killed when
we left our home the regime was still
shelling our houses are destroyed where
shall we go
one of Miriam's relatives is north her
struggle is even harder she's almost
nine months pregnant and she has another
daughter to look after not 30 they say
are a threat Dana we managed to hit to
ride to get here after hours of waiting
and asking people on the road since my
husband died eight months ago we've been
forced to move is depressing to think
that I'll give birth here it would be
better if I had my own tent this latest
wave of displacement seems to be
unprecedented the refugees are suffering
in the harsh winter weather the rain was
a major problem the tents were flooded
now it's snowing and keeping everyone
warm is even more difficult aid workers
in the field say they can't meet the
needs of so many people targets to give
you they are fleeing to either north it
Lib or to a free nor Azaz but it's
difficult to find a place there -
international humanitarian aid is
urgently needed that's the only way to
suffice the syrian army captured the
strategic crossroads town of sarahyap on
Friday after weeks long offensive
against the country's lost rebel
stronghold and at that just a few months
ago Sarah Cobb counted some 110 thousand
residents but now it's a ghost town
and for the children of Soraka their
destiny is to suffer through yet another
Syrian tragedy
cynalco sólo al jazeera adlib
northwestern Syria